hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast exosome biogenesis and the
budding of proteins and viruses i am dr.
chad schwartz senior application
scientist at beckman coulter and i'll be
your moderator for today's event we were
delighted to bring you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by beckman coulter back when
culture is a leader in centrifugation
and flow cytometry and has long been an
innovator in particle characterization
lab automation and genomics that when
culture products are used at the
forefront of important areas of
investigation and discovery for more
information please visit beckman coulter
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
at the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the icon in
the lower right hand corner of your list
of the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems to the green Q&A button I would
not like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Steven gold dr. gold is a professor
biological chemistry at John Hopkins
University in Baltimore Baltimore
Maryland dr. gold received his PhD from
the University of California at San
Diego where he studied the molecular
mechanisms of peroxisome biogenesis in
1991 he moved to an independent position
at the kennedy krieger institute and the
johns hopkins university where he
continued his studies of proxies own
biology and proxies animal diseases in
2003 dr. goldberg and his foray into
exosome biology and HIV budding by
co-authoring the trojan exosome
hypothesis with this collaborator dr.
james hildreth dr. gold's research has
since focused on molecular mechanisms of
intercellular vesicle traffic retrovirus
but budding and the translational
applications of these processes dr.
Gould also serves as the president of
the American Society for exosomes and
microvesicles before we get started I
would like to ask a few Pope
to our audience our first poll question
is what separation technique are you
currently using to isolate exosomes
ultracentrifugation of a differential
gradient affinity capture size exclusion
or precipitation reagents please select
one of the four answers and we'll give a
few time a bit of time for the audience
to respond and i will then disseminate
the results all right our results are in
it looks like sixty percent of folks in
attendance use ultra standard deviation
or differential gradients twenty percent
use affinity capture zero percent at
size exclusion chromatography and twenty
percent are at precipitation reagents
our second and final question will be
populating here shortly
what is your sample source for
extracting or isolating exosomes tissues
cell culture blood urine plasma or other
exosomes come from a variety of sources
please just select the one that you are
using in your research a few more
moments as the audience response and an
overwhelming majority you cell culture
at 80 three-point-three percent and
sixteen percent use plasma I would like
to thank everyone for their answers and
I will now turn it over to dr. Steven
gold for his presentation good morning
thanks Chad um thanks for having me I'm
just trying to UM okay so yeah i'm
stephen jay gould welcome yeah i'm in
the department of biological chemistry
at johns hopkins university and i want
to speak to you today about exosome
biogenesis and protein budding a better
study before i get into that though i
just want to make sure everybody's aware
of the upcoming meeting in the american
society for exosomes and microvesicles i
see the 2050s can be held in late
october beautiful resort island Marco
Island in Florida and we're having
approximately 200 attendees and we're
happy to announce this year the beckman
coulter is our primary sponsor for this
event so if please register for the
meeting and you can do so on line at a
sem v org and i look forward to seeing
you all in florida now just a little bit
of background before we get into the
need of the time
and what are exosomes what are we really
talking about also they are in my
opinion secreted vesicles and a variable
diameter depending upon the cell type in
which they are derived from around 50 to
250 nanometers they have the same
topology of the cell they really have no
other defining physico-chemical
properties and they're released by all
animal cells tested now the term exosome
was originally coined by transat all and
in their paper that you find exosome is
secreted vesicles that quote may serve a
physiological function I think this is a
very reasonable definition now at rules
of exosomes in normal physiology are
quite varied and I like to think of them
in terms of whether they are playing a
role for the vesicle producing cell or
whether they're playing a role in
signaling to other cells and describe
these as cell-autonomous affects some
non autonomous effects and in the cell
autonomous effects there's good evidence
that they're playing rules and perky
quality control in cell polarity
differentiation and modulation of
extracellular matrix and of course the
great interest in this field now is in
nocella non autonomous effects and
intracellular transfer of signals and
molecules genetic information a great
example of the role of exosomes and
protein quality control was published
just last year by Gavin Wright and
colleagues and in which they were
studying the protein Juno which is the
sperm receptor on the surface of
mammalian eggs and so the upper panel of
this upper left panel of this image you
can see prior to fertilization amino
staining for the Juno protein is quite
right at the surface of the egg and
after fertilization the Proteus rapidly
lost from the cell surface and when dr.
Wright workers looked at what was going
on and what they found is that the
protein just was butted straight off the
surface of the cell and this is shown in
the bottom panels here we have the
prior to fertilization and you can see
the amino gold labeling for the Juna
protein right at the cell surface but
then shortly after fertilization it's
absent from the cell surface he no
longer seen union standing here and
instead the immunostaining is present in
dust Cole's just off the surface of the
egg is the beautiful demonstration role
of exosomes modulating the protein
content at the plasma membrane as I
mentioned most most current interest in
exosomes are as intracellular vesicle
traffic y vehicles and this is a
beautiful cartoon in which one can see
the exosomes interacting the cells in
various ways by engaging cell surface
receptors perhaps fusing at the cell
surface being endocytosed perhaps using
after endocytosis with the net effect
that information both signaling
information and actual transfer
molecules and genetic information can be
mediated by this pathway now
intracellular vesicle trafficking has
been implicated in New signaling in germ
cell maturation winds signaling
angiogenesis tissue repair
transdifferentiation in stem cell
biology and many other processes there
are also played very important roles in
impacted physiological situations in
cancer we know that there are cell no
cell autonomous effects and thus
vesicular secretion of into cancer drugs
particularly doxorubicin it's been
reported um engaging this pathway
putting more car goes into this pathway
appears to induce amoeboid morphology
and Annie Boyd morphology in cancer is
highly correlated with aggressive
metastatic cancers and also degradation
of extracellular matrix demonstrated by
number of lens but again also vesicles
released by cancer cells have been shown
to contribute to the bystander effect
whereby cancer cells alter the
physiology and gene expression profiles
of the neighboring stromal cells also in
their degenerative diseases where
they're involved in the transmission
of pathology or in the case of prion
disease is actually transmission of the
infectious protein and and a particular
interest in our lab involved in viral
biogenesis HIV and other retroviruses
but also hepatitis C virus and even non
envelope viruses like the corner viruses
poliovirus coxsackie hepatitis A virus
these actually are emitting from cells
within vesicles and can be taken up in
that form as well and the infectious so
the very important and the importance of
the vesicles is reflected in the fact
that there have been recognized by NIH
as a topic to be studied under the NIH
Common Fund and particularly the
extracellular RNA communication
consortium and I just show you here the
link to their really beautiful web show
about extracellular RNA and their role
exosomes in transferring that out of the
salad in other cells now a little bit
about how exosomes are purified as Chad
mentioned differential centrifugation is
commonly used is what we use almost
exclusively in our lab and it still
remains the gold standard but there are
other techniques for purifying exosomes
polymer induced precipitations
filtration the membrane of gel and fit
your application using lectins
antibodies to specific markers have all
been used but the technique that we use
in our lab and that will we use
beginning again for the types of
experiments I'm talking about today is
outlined here where we simply remove
cells by a low speed spin past the
supernatant through a point two micron
filter do a couple of 30 minutes spins
at 10 kg in which we transfer the
supernatant over them for high speed
ultracentrifugation for an hour and we
arrived with a population of vesicles
that are shown in this electron
micrograph these are exosomes released
by human t cells in culture very uniform
size and about
to 80 nanometers in diameter and a
fairly indistinct morphology now
exosomes been considered together with
many other types of extracellular
vesicles and various different names
have been going to discuss extracellular
vesicles exosomes exes and like vesicles
microvesicles micro particles and one
can find cartoons like this this is from
ab cam but in many reviews in which cut
characteristics and definitions are
offered in terms types of proteins that
are found their sizes of densities etc
and I would just simply comment that
there's really not an awful lot of
evidence to support these definitions
and another weakness of many of these is
that it really does almost always emit
viruses and virus like particles even
though many cells in particular cancer
cells are producing large amounts of
virus like particles so when one can
think of the extracellular vesicles
hydrogen ad issue as having a spectrum
of views one extreme you can have this
literature you we're really all of these
variations in vesicle size and
composition are reflecting independent
mechanisms of vesicle biogenesis each
mechanism generating a distinct type of
vesicle as distinct non overlapping sets
of cargo molecules and sort of splitters
on a dream field now you can go to the
other end of the extreme and have the
lumpers view that the heterogeneity
really isn't reflecting multiple
mechanisms of biogenesis but rather just
a casting variation in a single primary
mechanism and the reality is that it is
probably lies somewhere in between these
two but the truth of matter is right now
we don't really know because we don't
know much about the actual mechanisms of
vesicle biogenesis now when I talk about
today is not a lot of general models but
rather actual primary data and I want to
draw your attention to people who
actually do the work for instance for
juror
graduate student in my lab but also I've
been blessed by having a number of
really great students work for me over
the last few years German yangshan Gann
Ming Wu begi Shen Amy booth of all made
major contributions in my lab to try and
understand how vesicles or made how
proteins bud and the relationship
between that process and how viruses but
from cells and I do want to mention of
James hildreth and a document hildreth
professor of pharmacology heard Hopkins
for many years who's they now gone on to
take his research first up to Harry
medical college and then out to UC Davis
where he served as dean of biological
sciences and I believe he's now back at
meharry this year and as Nina the
medical school so these people have made
major contributions to what I'm going to
be discussing now one way to think about
the work we do in my lab is that we take
a big cargo based approach to study
excellent biogenesis rather than
focusing on vesicle of this type of
vesicle that type of vesicle we focus
really on a protein or a set of proteins
and I'm going to talk about just a small
number of them today and all right goal
in these studies to identify and
characterize the sis acting targeting
information in these proteins what are
the parts of the protein what's the what
are those elements that really are
sufficient to give the protein to sites
the vesicle budding out of the cell in
exosomes all right ideally and went down
the road we'd like to identify and
characterize the transacting factors now
the gene products and genes in the cell
that are involved in that process of
recognizing xso mcCargo proteins
delivering them decide somebody and
making the vesicles getting this car go
see any threat and then based on the
data that we obtained from these kinds
of studies based our goal is to develop
and test mechanistic models of exosome
biogenesis and I think this general
pathway will be successful in this field
it's the it's the general approach
that's been used in cell biology for
several decades now to elicit eight
pathways of organ abiogenesis
for organelles that exists inside the
cell so what is what is the current view
exosome biogenesis most people view
exosomes as vesicles that are only made
by budding ended mpus ohms and then
released only after and the somes fuse
with the plasma membrane and that's sort
of view is shown in this cartoon on the
right where you have vesicle budding and
for budding domains and limiting
membrane of the endosome these these bud
and pinch off to form intraluminal
vesicles which then accumulate we get a
multi particular body for me and then
that moves to the plasma membrane docks
engages fuses and the visas exosomes in
a pulsatile manner now the when we
started working in this field we started
looking in a human t cells for reasons
that will become a later and other
leukocytes and when we stay in these
cells for using antibodies to detect
exosome cargo proteins such as cd63 a
shirt on the top panel cd81 shown on the
top panel or looking at what we're known
to be exosome of lipid cargos modified
forms of phosphatidylethanolamine PE are
trafficked by cells des cités affects
somebody and you can see on the left of
both of these images the concentration
of these fluorescent forms of PE a
distinctive aims of the plasma membrane
so here's the phase image to the right
for these and here we have our exosome
Accardo proteins as well and what you
see actually is that the proteins our
community the street domains of the
plasma membrane and when we saw this we
are instead bit surprised to find these
XS o mccoggins at the cell surface
although perhaps we should have been
given that these proteins are actually
CD proteins which means that they were
defined by their existence of the plasma
but we found them at the plasma membrane
found them in discrete domains and a ye
thing student who is doing some of this
work at the time
dailybooth realize that this was the
this had been seen before it might give
us clues as to what's going on
furthermore what we showed is that these
proteins were not really at the cell
surface but they were budding directly
from the cell surface and you can see
that here with cd81 containing vesicle
budding straight from the plasma
membrane and also again in this image as
well now as I mentioned this is
reminiscent of other observations in
filled with cell biology and
particularly the capping and shedding of
cross lead cell surface proteins and
this actually was a fairly intensive
area investigation in the late 60s and
early 70s Marty raff run away and others
a lot of homework studies in this area
and essentially what they showed is that
if you had a protein like cd43 on a
lymphocyte and you stained it state the
living cells you'd see that it was all
over the cell surface but now if you
added a crosslinking secondary antibody
what what happened is a rather short
rather quickly the proteins came to
exist in just a single pole of the
plasma membrane this was thought to be
driven by the binding energy of mutually
multivalent antibody antigen reactions
it's allowed by the fact that you have a
fluid plasma membrane which allows
diffusion lateral diffusion in the
plasma membrane and you get these caps
forming a single pole and it was shown
in a small number of studies that these
cat proteins are subservient
subsequently released on membrane
vesicles it didn't really attract a lot
of attention this latter part but what
came to our minds was that this could
actually be the targeting information
presence I each a simple aggregation or
high order organization might be what's
driving proteins the blood from cells so
following up on that and experiments
were done in which the labeled a t-cell
with antibodies to cd43 which does not
normally bud from human t cells and we
also label them with our HPE and you can
see that here it defines the cap of
where
exosomes are being made of these cells
he's just a small domain of the plasma
membrane now if you take these cells and
you add a secondary antibody to cross
with the cd43 it goes to these cats and
what you can see here is that the number
of vesicles that are now labeled green
goes up a couple orders of magnitude and
by immunoblot and we actually don't get
anyone years will bust and increasing
the budding but you can see it also hear
that after the cross-linking the
antibody you can see it come off in
exosomes so this upper panel with a cell
associated levels in the bottom so high
order oligomerization is targeting
plasma membrane proteins the sites of
budding in into exosomes themselves and
we should we showed this for a large
number of cell surface proteins so it's
not that the cargo proteins in these
instances have a classical type of
targeting signal they really don't
normally go to exosomes but you can get
them to go to exosomes simply by adding
a primary antibody in the cross-linking
secondary antibody to cause essentially
their aggregation plasma numbering now
we also asked was the corollary that
were true if we took a protein that we
know forms high order oligomers in the
cytoplasm but doesn't normally but for
themselves can we get that too bud by
putting it into a cell remembering so
for this we turn to a protein called cya
it's actually a yeast protein never it's
part of the else the gy 1 LTR
retrotransposon in East and this is a
non-viral element if never buds from the
cells if you express it in mammalian
cells as shown in the upper left here
you see that it just piles up in a
cytoplasm of community cell and again it
does not fun and this is our site of
money okay so that does have these
plasma membrane domains in this
particular cell enriched for the exosome
lithography but now if we simply add 10
amino acids to the n terminus of this
protein we find that now it not only
goes to the plasma membrane but it goes
to these cats
we're colocalizes with exosome Oh marker
proteins and if you look at how these
proteins bud and here the upper panel of
exosome fractions and the bottom panel
is the cell associated fraction you can
see that the tya protein refuse these
proteins to gfp by the way that it's
expressed quite well in these cells but
it does not but from cells so nothing is
out of these cells but if you know take
this protein that has this 10 amino acid
tag at the n-terminus and this tag
specifies Marissa latian at this glycine
position right here the protein now is
expressed well and bloods well from
cells which you can see quite well here
it actually buds from self just as well
as HIV gag which is a viral capsid
protein the buds meeting somebody with
HIV if you mutate that vicen residue the
protein no longer associates with
remembering no longer bloodstream
yourself so basically I did adding a
plasma membrane induces the body of this
high order of wigan Eric complex protein
tya from cells know if one looks at the
exosomes one derives from these cells
it's kind of interesting I mentioned
before that these particular cells make
exosomes of a very uniform size about 50
to 80 nanometers but when we express
this one protein acyl tya and we find
that it actually accumulates quite well
and secreted vesicles you can see by the
arrows in the slide you get there
pointing not to the membrane between an
electron-dense lamina just under the
membrane that's composed in the key whey
protein and not only does it change the
morphology of these exosomes to portland
we now more resemble a virus-like
particle but the sizes and shapes and
densities in vesicles chains also just
by expression one protein carga the
sizes tend to be larger they go up to
200 nanometer 300 no no mcerlain
they then be very irregular and they
have tails on them sometimes and the
density is much higher than normal so
properties like size shape density are
determined by the cargo proteins that
are put into the vesicle and simply
expressing one protein in a cell can
change these now we've looked at other
plasma membrane anchors to see how they
function in terms of being able to
reduce the Buddy of tya and other high
order oligomeric proteins and what we
find is that there's a large number of
plasma membrane anchors that can do the
job I mentioned previously that rest
elation tag again this is a 10 amino
acid sequence but really all that's
essential is this glycine position two
of the protein if that's a glycine then
it's quite likely to be recognized by
the missile transferase and protein will
be isolated at that position you can put
at the c-terminus ventilation
palmitoylation tag and that will also be
sufficient to induce the budding of T by
a at the n-terminus if we put in a pip
three binding domain so this is from
rookie act it binds the philosophy of
against all three four five Tris
phosphate which is present in for the
plasma membrane that's sufficient to
induce the budding to binding domain can
also be done and again what I want to
point out is you can anchor this protein
in the plasma membrane at the n-terminus
and it's see tremors by isolation by
lipid binding domain and any of them are
sufficient to get the perking the blood
from cells vesicles in fact I mentioned
to you earlier that protein cd43 that
does not normally bud from cells if I
can be in used to bud by adding extra
cellular cross-linking antibodies well
you can also get that protein to bud by
adding a high-order oligomeric protein
to c terminus confused scene 43 to the
key why a protein now you find that it
goes to sites the vesicle budding and
those from the cell and in excess
now what these data show us is that when
we're we're asking a question of where
these types of high-order oligomeric
complexes but from cells it appears to
be that it's the plasma membrane curves
in a very good job of inducing there
buddy but what about if we target the
same card on proteins like a salty why I
mean tya if we use a different type of
lipid binding domain and we target them
to the embassy what happens then well
that's shown in this slide what we've
done is we fused qya to a tandem
duplication of the pi3 binding fitty
domain so this 50 domain here binds to
hospital national three phosphate which
is an abundant lipid in the cytoplasmic
face at the end of some membrane and
what we find is that the targets of tya
gfp protein to these internal organelles
they you not obviously co-localize with
the exosome Accardo lipid here although
they do co-localize within in the soma
Margaret you can see these on lower pain
and if we ask how well it buds not too
well so it is a comparison of the
budding of the acyl tya gfp Perkins
where we put the key why a in the plasma
membrane by virtue of that Marissa
latian site it buds very well from the
cell that's reflected here actual
quantification from multiple trials
you'll notice that the budding of the
end assembly targeted form is not zero
it's about 1% and there actually is a
band here if you look carefully now
Weaver said it points to a band so it's
not that it's inconsistent with buddy
it's just that it's not very efficient
at inducing the budding of proteins
and you know the confirmation that
exosomes came back from the plasma
membrane of these cells is shown here
where we're looking at cells that are
expressing that acyl to I a protein and
on which cd43 has been crosslink with
antibodies and this top panel you can
see that all these cargoes arco
localizing the street their names of the
plasma membrane worst image and at the
ultrastructural level what you see is
cell surface largely devoid of letting
profiles except at one patch of the cell
just one pole of the cell where you see
all the vesicles budding from the cell
and is just high increasingly high
magnifications in this process so the
conclusion that this to this first part
of the talk is that a protein buddy is
induced by high order organization and
plasma membrane binding but the
targeting the same cargo proteins to the
endosomal membrane in our hands at least
does not induce sufficient protein buddy
the main takeaway here is a plasma
membrane needs to be considered as a
major site of perking budding and not
just all any kind of protein but exosome
local teens as well and this is
important particularly for future
translational studies of exosomes if the
goal of the research being funded by NIH
and other organizations is to go beyond
understanding of the basic biology and
actually to translate that information
to making vesicles that we can load with
cargoes that we want and target to cells
and tissues that we want we need to know
the rules that the cell uses for
targeting proteins to exosomes and they
copy those rules the bottom line is this
if you have a protein that you want to
target into exosome for some therapeutic
purpose targeted to the endosomal
membrane is not actually going to get
you there very efficiently whereas
targeting it to the plasma membrane or
doing much better job
okay i want to add in another layer of
into the talk which is that a virus body
shown here is a cartoon of retro virus
life cycle well you know the virus
particle on the far left up and left
coming to a cell engaging with its
receptors and pro receptors fusing the
membrane between the plasma between the
cell and the virus you have a nun coding
process where the capsid gets out in the
cytoplasm it translocates to the nucleus
or those reverse transcription and then
integration of the proviral DNA and then
from that provirus expression of rnase
translation of proteins Assembly of a
new particle and budding of that
particle from the plasma membrane this
is the out basic and then once it's
about it you have the maturation step
and then you have a fully functional
retrovirus ready to infect another cell
now in studies bone games held with and
many others it's become clear that HIV
particles bear a great number of
similarities to exosomes they have the
same basic topology they have almost
exactly the same size they have the same
host lipids the same host proteins and
studies on the carbohydrate profile of
the glycoproteins and glycolipids show
that they have very similar carbohydrate
signatures as well on their
extracellular domains now this led James
and I number of years ago to explore
this idea that retrovirus funny / daily
HIV Betty is a form of exosome
biogenesis clearly in addition to the
similarities in the finished particles
that are released up from the cell
there's parallels in the cell biology
where you have a lot of evidence for
endosomal budding a lot of evidence for
plasma membrane buddy in both cases and
this led us to this protein exosome
hypothesis that Chad mentioned earlier
and which is just diagram right here in
these two slides but when retro viruses
infect the cell
there are no capsid proteins and other
structural proteins are viewed by the
cell and treated by the cell essentially
is access or more cargo proteins they're
targeted the sites of exosome biogenesis
and they use the exosome biogenesis
pathways to make it infectious variant
now some of the supporting evidence for
this comes from isolated studies of the
bible gag protein not just the virus
itself so just an overview of retrovirus
structure the proviral genome consists
of ltrs flanked by several of reading
frames that encode for all recognizes
gag a gag pole fusion protein pole
encodes the reverse transcriptase
integrates Proteus functions and then
the envelope protein a separate protein
is made from the spliced transcript off
the proviral genome now a large number
of studies over the years have
established that it's not the envelope
protein that mediates inviting
themselves for retroviruses but rather
it's the gag protein that means the
buggy so to study virus budding many
people in the retro biology field the
study the running gag protein and that's
where we initially put our focus as well
one of the things we observe right off
the bat was that if you look at the
expression of gag in human key cells you
find that it also goes to these cap
domains of the cell surface where it
colocalizes with cd81 cd63 from here
again so consistent with the notion that
gag HIV gag is treated as a cargo the
exosome biogenesis pathway now if one
takes another view of retroviruses do
the gag proteins actually have these
features that we found to target
proteins to sites a vesicle buddy and
into exosomes it turns out they give all
gag proteins and have some type of
applause from the membrane anchor it can
be a nurse
relation signal it can be a picture
binding domain it can be both in case of
HIV actually has both of 50 binding
domain and our installation side and
also gag proteins have multiple
organization domains which is what you
need in order to form a high order
oligomerization on the way thinking
about that is that they form controlled
aggregates so in the case of HIV gaggy
of a matrix region that as a triangle
ization domain a captured region that is
a heck civilization of main nucleocapsid
which has some dimerization activity of
course the gap protein is named by the
products that are generated by the
action of the bible protease so if you
just express gag you express this entire
protein the whole 55 kill adult and
protein matrix capsid and see as well as
the space for peptides in p6 give me all
of that it is the gag p55 protein we're
mostly going to be just concerned with
the budding of that protein not how it
gets cleaned by protease or what all the
different sub parts in the egg protein
and for anyway so the gag pockets all
look like cargos they all behave like
cargos because when you express them in
mammalian cells they all go to sites of
the circle budding and they come out of
the cell and association with exosome or
markers i'm not showing the budding in
the slide just the intracellular
localization and the point is that they
all colocalize with accessible cargo so
here's the budding of equine infectious
anemia virus protein htlv-1 protein
uring leukemia virus protein rous
sarcoma virus Mason finds a monkey virus
the endogenous curve k that we all
express all have in our genomes and all
express they all go to sites of budding
and but from cells in exosomes and this
is not true for for a class of viruses
that are related to retroviruses bit
different send me in foaming virus gag
like protein
not bad from cells does not localize to
snipe somebody is not come out of the
cell melon systems so it's a general
feature it's not a specific thing for
HIV is true of all retroviruses cells
treat them as bad proteins and you can
see this at the ultrastructural level as
well here's a cell infected with HIV and
amino stained with antibodies to see be
81 and you can see here the amino gold
label / c dat one at this budding
profile and we know it's a budding
profile because it has an electron-dense
gaggle edema and that's true also these
images below and not just that the cd81
is on the virus particle but it's in the
vicinity of the budding and it's
demonstrating here even in the name or
nascent flooding as well if one collects
the vesicles from cells that are
expressing gag and expressing a lipid
marker of exosomes here rhodamine label
PE one can simply drive them onto the
glass and ask the question of whether
they're not there localizing at the same
vesicles so to the right panel each of
these is a vesicle dried down onto a
glass slide and imaged to detect the
rota means game and then took a picture
look at the GFP stain and gag gfp is
present only inside only in vesicles
that are also labeled with the ex
assemble marker now that data suggests
that when HIV buds or HIV gag buds its
budding from exosomes if that's true
then if we just artificially
cross-linked any protein and get it into
the exosome pathway in cells that are
also expressing gaggle or infected with
HIV it should target those onto virus
like particles and target them onto the
baryons so here i'm just showing you
again what happens when you cap cd43 and
the t-cell if these t-cell is expressing
at the same time a dsred form tag gag
you find the co-localize at the same
domains of the plasma membrane right out
here
okay and if you collect the exosomes
from these cells and you dry them on
glass and visualize them by fluorescence
microscopy you can see the vesicles all
these vesicles that are labeled with a
red label gag in circles and these are
the ones that are also labeled with the
cross-linked cd43 so this is cd43 that's
been stained with Anna primary antibody
crossed with a secondary antibody and
then the vesicles collected from the
culture supernatant dried down and you
can find cd43 now on vesicles they hurt
also containing gag you can do this in
cells that are infected with HIV and get
the same sort of result to the left
panel here is HIV buddy from G Psalms
these T cells were staying with
antibiotics to cd43 but we did not cap
the cd43 and one can find some cd43 in
the area design there's one gold
particle I believe right down here but
they're not enriched in this area cd40
threes everywhere so it's not excluded
from sexy body this is not enriched in
sexified but if now we cap cd43 and we
look at the brain density within
immunogold stains much higher we find
evidence for these cross-linked cd43
complexes on the HIV particle and the
increase is roughly 20 fold in cd43
concentration on the phone great HIV
particles now one thing I also mentioned
early on was that and the exosome
protein sorting pathway is involved in
polarization of cells particularly we
referred to as amoeboid polarization
cancer cells but also in the
polarization of leukocytes which also
form the anterior posterior polarity and
when cells do adopt this type of
polarity they have a year apart at the
posterior pole here's the neural pod at
the back of the cell there are certain
proteins that are known upon
polarization to go to this domain and
cd43 interesting enough is one of these
when it does so what you also
I know the exosome Oh cargos go into
this demon and the point on reason I'm
bringing this up in this talking about
HIV is that if you now look at where HIV
galgos in cells that are polarized in
this manner so here's a human neutrophil
like cell line hl-60 we modify to
express HIV gag gfp when we put it on a
plate and gave it a chemoattractant the
chemo track that's coming out of this
pipe at you can see this neutral field
here is migrating rapidly towards this
pipette tip this is anterior and the
posterior pole it's your pod extension
is letting it rightly for HIV gag and if
you look at these cells at the
ultrastructural level what you see in
here's the interior end of these cells
and cheerio polity cells here's the
posterior pole of these cells and apt to
confirm the posterior protocells you see
exosomes buddy you see virus-like
particles budding offer this and so
again there's this correlation that
shows up again and again and again
whatever you find it not exosome
biogenesis of excellent protein
trafficking that pretty much holds true
also for the trafficking of HIV gag into
the budding of gag virus like particles
and budding for HIV virus particles in
regular infection is welcome now this
notion that James and I have a long time
ago about HIV being approaching exosome
retroviruses being Trojan exosome
actually also has some relevance for how
we think about the evolution of
electrolyzers for many years retrovirus
field has believed that retroviral
evolution was driven was initiated
primarily by the transduction of an
envelope type gene LTR retrotransposons
which were cousin in organisms like
yeast that don't have any envelope on
this money they have a gag like protein
and a gag pole like fusion protein like
bioelectric long terminal repeats and of
course retroviruses have this other gene
beyond the gene so obviously it's a
major event in retro viral
the acquisition of envelope gene but for
that to be the defining transition
between retrovirus and electro
transposon is asking an awful lot of
that on gene that i'm jean has to you
know get the capsid structural protein
the genomic RNA into the membrane gives
it a membrane it has to mediate it's
flooding from the cells it has to be
media combining to other cells and they
asked me need the fusing with other
cells and if it doesn't do all those
four things it really doesn't get any
selective advantage to the transmission
of this retro element and I ex assemble
view of this evolutionary process is a
little bit simpler in an organism that
already is doing exosome biogenesis and
intracellular exosome trafficking you
don't need all of those events in fact
you don't even need the transduction of
an envelope Genie all you really need is
a glycine substitution mutation at
position two of whatever this main
structural protein is a gag like protein
because if that's a glide if that
becomes a glycine now it's subject to
being missed elated that will traffic
the structural protein to the membrane
to sites of vesicle budding and given
that these structural proteins bind the
genomic RNA and we'll bring the RNA into
the vesicles if these vesicles and these
exosomes being released are transmitting
from cell to cell gives the ability of
the retro element to get into the
cytoplasm of a neighboring cell and then
complete a pathway of a cytoplasmic and
nuclear replication so it initiates in
one cell over here with the expression
of the rnase in the proteins leads to
the budding of these nascent proto
deariens and they'll release out into
the cytoplasm emtrey and they're
reinfection of another cell so this is
makes possible the transmission of a
transposable element into a virus just
by a single point mutation in one print
so to summarize this part of the talk up
I'd like to say that the evidence is
pretty clear that retro gag proteins are
targeted decisive exosome biogenesis and
secreted from the cell and exosomes the
HIV virus itself is letting from cells
together with X assemble markers and
that high order oligomers a shin is
sufficient to target plasma membrane
proteins to HIV particles now things are
pretty convincing set of data but really
when you look at the HIV field you don't
see a lot of people modeling it as an
exosome and you know this is reflected
in the use of a lot of people and
including NIH and this is just a really
sort of sharp reminder of this this year
NIH put out an RFA titled which is to
explore the role of exosomes in HIV
pathogenesis and in the instructions for
the application because it says that the
beta education will not be not being if
you study study the use of the use of
the exosome biogenesis pathway for HIV
elimination so it's hard to get traction
with this idea in the HIV community in
general and with NIH funding and why is
this after all I've told you that the
gag proteins looked for all the world
like a nexus o mcCargo they have a
member a new anchor and they have
multiple ization domains they form very
large organized aggregates fifty-
built-ins are larger and all you need
for that is matrix capsid in caps lonely
any other part of the gag protein
Florida and this gets to be part of the
problem with with the adoption of this
idea because in the HIV field has been
known for many many years now and this
was work initiated by Heinrich dawdling
or a kickin basil teens lab so going
back to paper published in 1991 and pap
ask if you look at the budding of HIV
from many different cell types you see
these also a kind of
here to the left panel of cell lysis of
what of a full HIV pro pro bono
survivors FML 43 and the cell associated
amount of the gag protein and how this
is the vesicle not releasing very honest
and we're looking for at the breakdown
products about gag starts off as p55 but
then get shut down by the bar / / vs to
be 24 build Dalton's and our bodies are
specific for that 24 killer Dalton
capture the key piece of the protein
anyways um okay so infect cells with
virus you can see the gag poking in the
cells you can see the gag poke the bear
yawns not surprising everything was fine
what darling are and hazeltine said was
that if you had a mutation this mutation
called l1 term and this is a mutation
that stops protein right and after the
second spaced or peptide prevents the
synthesis of the p6 part of yeah you can
see it expressed in the cell the band
and what you don't see is a
corresponding band in the variance
actually you see son it completely
processed gag proteins mutants but you
don't see very much of them and so based
on this data it was concluded that the
PT 6 domain was necessary the body and
was actually mediating the body so this
actually runs quite counter to our
argument all you need is the major the
extreme regions of the alliteration
remains and everything binding amazing
tag in order to buy themselves and
furthermore people at HIV they feel less
I berquist and up there's tons beautiful
work actually finding this at a
hypnotist p6 role an atomic level and
biochemical level so it turns out that
in the p6 domain their sequences
dtap sequence that binds to component
into the escort one complex since tsg101
and these escort mission ruiz our
thoughts and catalyzed by this buddy
invesco bloody in general the ancestor
of our productions and i want to get
into all the data involved in this
question but i just want to point out
that even though it is quite clear that
lost the p6 in pain causes a defect in
body and the difference did reasons to
believe that it has something to do with
just you one-on-one interaction p6
domain um people kind of stopped doing
experiment at that point that would
question that model and given that we
were binding working from different
model we followed on and did some
experiments and push this idea crossing
this idea whether the p6 and Millie is
important for buddy I'm going to
summarize some of these right here it's
pretty straightforward stuff here's your
gag protein it's 55 killer the militants
and consists of sequences that can be
thought of as the composition of the
matrix got stood fp1 and CBS p 2 and p
six domains all is a single protein if
you express themselves in here Nelly
293t cells what you will find is that
you have stall so she amount of protein
and the protein buds really don't do
well if you make the the kind of
mutation that was reported by God when
the third those many years ago where you
simply stop expression of Jericho stop
coming right at the beginning of p62 me
we'll call this gag 1549 you get know
very little bite cincy there's very
little least in the exes infection and
if you give us multiple trials you can
quantify it in this Jose it's what we're
gonna fly for decrease anybody but
here's the curious thing um after
exactly a bloody went to dis experiments
I don't want to get into but we give
them if one delete further into Gallic
so now we go to gag g47 that's this
protein down here
okay and what you can see is that it's
it not only does not have the p16 name
it also doesn't happen that sp2 domain
so it's this consists of atrix caps at
SP 1 and z if you look at it's not even
it was great and that means quantified
here in multiple trials it's as good as
well so it seems that the budding defect
caused by loss of Pacific's really
wasn't the loss of peace FX it was the
exposure of a new c-terminus this sp2
leprosy turns and to tack up a little
bit further we took full length get back
protein and we simply added those 16
Elena classes of the SP 2 billion on the
c-terminus of it and asked whether it
could matter not and the results shown
here on the bottom is in panel c and you
can see the new blood and if some
fraction wild-type gag but it's very
well and then then you took that got ya
gagging speak to protein doesn't quite
hungry at all if you qualify it is
basically a 20-fold reduction in buddy
this guy guess but you so put mean the
sp2 peptide is extreme sitter muscle
protein HIV gag whether you're adding it
to the full yeah or you getting there by
completing p6 generates a protein that
cannot any longer but from cells for
some reason now it turns up it's a
trance it's a transferable property so
if you doubt take this 60 amino acids
from the spt domain and you added on to
other retroviral gag proteins they won't
let themselves anymore i'll just draw
your attention here the results with
htlv-1 in this panel here for this is
the cell associated or wild-type pokey
here's the budding if you'll be one gag
proteins in this Lane it slaps the yes
PQ domain is exposed to kelowna cells it
was very poorly from cells this is not
restricted to
regular gag proteins you can put it at
the c-terminus of cd63 and it locks
inhibits the budding of it as well we
even have completely synthetic cargoes
that quite well here's one just the
isolation domain name of the leucine
zipper detecting their protein buds for
cells pretty well but if we add this sp2
domain that is teach from this it
doesn't bud from cells anymore so this
is inhibitory budding signal is a sort
they are critically in the gag protein
it's exposed by certain communications
lab generated mutations but it's
probably a something interesting about
money because able to stop now working
from the gap protein and I with the S
peculiar the c-terminus we did a
mutation scan across and Halloweens
communication across that peptide and
identified residues that when mutated
eliminating this ability to block button
so here's the bunny wild gag is the sp2
doesn't like very well and here's the
plight of all various differently since
me again repeated and this allowed us to
identify functional Nino acids in this
individual signal and one of the things
we wanted to test was what did this
could explain the button with virus it's
important in the HIV field they take
whatever you find for the gag protein
and then replicated in the context of
the whole virus which is large showing
you the whole battle sequence here buddy
here's the regenerated permutations that
allowed us to do epistasis analysis of
HIV body so these have the p6 so much
further blocks buddy and then we've
added in other mutations in these sp2
demain either so we can look at the you
know the budding defect caused by the
mutant virus then whether now mutating
these individually lettings signal amino
acids could restore the body the bottom
line is they did no give us proper
processing but what can we come by these
I be expectations along with the p6 out
blunter mutation we get back normal
money so my conclusion here is that the
precise deletion of Pisa complaint
exposes a cryptic inhibitor buddies in
on hid the deletion point mutations in
this signal only stored by a p6
deficient Gaffigan HIV give us a much
more sophisticated view of what key six
is doing what it's why it's interacting
with escort machinery and how that
relates dividing your blindness and to
processing the virus by the protease and
giving us new insights into HIV biology
imposing new challenges for us to
include appeal and what I'd like to do
to finish up here yes is this the
surprise future directions in this field
obviously and we need to make a lot more
progress to elucidating working with the
mechanisms protein buddy we need to
explore their contribution to virus
budding especially for retroviruses like
HIV and then translate these advances to
make synthetic exosomes the little
therapeutic specific cells and tissues
and with that I'll conclude my talk and
we might get you all please join us in
Florida October sixteenth 20th for ASTM
be 2015 and with that I will conclude my
and thank you very much for your
attention great thank you for
terrific presentation dr. Gould I am
excited that you're exosome church and
hypothesis is starting to gain some
traction before we get started on our
question-and-answer session i would like
to remind our audience that you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box at the lower left of the
presentation window throughout the
presentation we have received several
good questions our first one is in
regards to inhibiting exosome formation
by blocking in sm ace enzymes for
example does that also block HIV budding
well yeah there's this there's reports
of the original report by on IQ pivotal
in science reported that it is not walk
so there are it's also cleared but some
excess amo cargos are not blocked by
inhibiting NSM these enzymes as well so
great thank you for that answer dr.
Gould our second question and a theme
throughout our questions that came in
are what methods are you able to
separate exosomes from virus particles
yeah on the stand method for separating
them from virus particles is based on
density and that's allowed because the
virus particles usually incorporate very
large amounts of their major capsid
protein into the vesicles which changes
the density so in my opinion those still
or excess pounds at a different density
but you can for let's say from
hiv-infected cells you can separate
exercise rooms that have the fully
formed caps it inside of
from the exercises that do not have four
cats inside it for them responded
density centrifugation gradient great
thanks a lot for that unfortunately
we're out of time today I want to thank
the audience for their interesting
questions and participation in today's
event I would also like to thank our
sponsor beckman coulter and of course
dr. Steven gold for making today's
educational webcast possible this
presentation will also be available
on-demand viewing through beckman
coulter com thanks again goodbye